[Music]
the concept of thinking in terms of a
distant future that we can arrive at is
one that I find exciting and necessary
we found that if you take people out of
the city you take them out of cellphone
range you put them in a context that can
start conversation and that's really
what the clock project is about it's
about starting different types of
conversation that you
and this place really does that and get
up into the crystalline forest and
you're looking at Bristol County step
that were probably saplings when the
great pyramids were being
5,000 years ago it immediately achieves
the goal that the clock is trying to
achieve and so we want to see how people
react to that and see how we can
capitalize on what's already natural
beauty and power of the site and how we
can enhance them for this it's actually
pretty rare that a man-made
enhances a natural site we want to show
you that
[Music]
the long now has always been an
exercises sort of stretching your mind
and accepting responsibility for more or
at least grasping more in your in your
thinking patterns and this is a natural
place for so doing that spatially - so
would be here and when you stand up on
top of that mountain and you look for
hundreds of miles in every direction you
really have a sense of how small an
individual human is and the on the earth
and it's pretty unspoiled stuff that you
see in every direction and so for us
it's a sense of responsibility - but
kind of keeping that unspoiled
[Music]
it's a monument to an idea it certainly
reflects thoughtfulness that I deeply
appreciate and then I'm really delighted
to be able to play a small part
[Music]
there's this weird dichotomy in the
sense that we really do want to build
something that's gonna last for 10,000
years we really do want to leave this
for the future but that's not really why
we're doing it we're really doing it so
that people today to get them to think
to get them to expand their time
horizons so that they can think not just
about this quarter this fiscal year this
presidential election but to get them to
think about these long-term problems
[Music]
I think the conversation that took place
out in the desert was the continuation
of one that's been going for a while and
that is going to be carrying on for a
long time yep and and yes I was part of
it but so was everyone else who attended
and so is everyone else who comes too
long now events and who becomes a member
and who watches the videos or listen to
the podcasts or engages with these ideas
at any level because it is finally not
about the origins of those ideas but
about you know what we do with
[Music]
one of the most interesting aspects of
being up there was sort of watching a
community begin to congeal before your
eyes and this is a multi-part and very
long term process obviously but there
are milestones along the way where you
can say you know something special
happened in this journey you know and I
think last week's trip to the Fox site
was one of those meetings
good evening I'm Peter Schwartz from the
long now foundation it's my pleasure and
privilege to introduce tonight's speaker
Stuart brand Stuart's been shaped I
don't have to give you his resume
everybody here know Stuart
but Stuart's been shaping the world of
culture and ideas in the Bay Area for 40
years and for a lot of that time I've
had the privilege of having him as a
friend and collaborator it's all about
the questions it began with the question
why haven't we seen a picture of the
whole earth yet and in all the years
we've worked together what Stuart has
done is always asked the hard questions
and tonight he'll be asking the hard
questions that he asked so well in his
brilliant new book whole earth
discipline and he'll be asking the hard
questions tonight that led him to
rethink Green and may lead you to
rethink Green Stuart brand
[Applause]
you know this talk is gonna be a little
bit like firing a bullet through my book
it'll touch on a few things miss most
and not take very long and the book
title I know it sounds like it's whole
earth catalogue revisited some of it is
but mostly it's not because this time
the title is used literally instead of
decoratively it means the population at
the planets whole climate and its whole
population the world population is about
6.8 billion now and of that the
developing the developed countries are
1.1 billion in developing countries 5.7
billion that means 5 out of 6 of us live
in the developing world that's the
crucial fact in the developing world our
lives are changing drastically mostly
for the better as we move into town
create jobs and educate our kids our
countries and developing world are
building infrastructure and we are still
learning about the critical value of
natural infrastructure forests aquifer
biodiversity and a predictable climate
in the developing world we control most
of the planet's land surface or in
Africa or in Asia or in Latin America
and we are on the move toward
opportunity wherever it may be most of
that opportunity is in the cities that's
why we're going there it's the dominant
demographic event of this century is the
screamingly rapid urbanization by
mid-century the whole world will be
about 80% urban the way the developed
world is now and that's the sequence the
developed world past the 50 percent
urban point back in the nineteen fifty
the developing world is going to get
there very shortly and a balance of
power will shift nearly all the action
in the developing world in the global
south and
when you compare it to what happened in
Europe and North America the developing
world is urbanizing three times faster
and nine times bigger now supposedly the
world's largest cities are always the
drivers of history as we see from
looking at history we now have a
district distribution of urban power
similar to a thousand years ago in other
words the rise of the West was great but
it's over the aggregate numbers are
overwhelming every week 1.3 million 1.3
million new people in town some of their
born there most are moving there the
question is what's the attraction action
this is Kibera it's bustling squatter
city outside Nairobi everybody's busy
getting the hell out of poverty as fast
as possible squatters are grassroots
entrepreneurs if you can't find a job
create a job same thing with your house
same thing with your town here's an
equally busy Lane and a doughy slum
another busy Lane mm one of Mumbai's
many slums and a busy market in racine
yo one of the three O's countless
favelas this is urban life at its
densest and social capital at its
richest everybody in the slum
neighborhood knows each other well
whether they want to or not because
what's going on is this intense mystery
called the informal economy which
specializes in being visible to itself
and invisible to authorities it's huge
economists have not yet figured out how
it works or taken much account of how it
feeds the formal economy of nations and
feeds the world so for example in Mumbai
The Economist's are still catching on
that slums do not undermine posterity
they helped create it Mumbai is said to
be half slums it is also on the six of
the gross domestic product of all of
India the informal economy
steals electricity from the formal
economy this is homemade infrastructure
here's a dramatic slum interface in Sao
Paulo if you take a close look at that
edge you see something interesting
cities specialize in jamming ways of
life together and thereby creating value
to put supply right next to demand here
the crooks and the maids and the
gardener's and the guards and the lively
part of town on the Left walk to work in
the boring rich neighborhood on the
right proximity is amazing it's like a
coral reef of humanity proximity
empowers urban intensity is that it's
most resourceful and working slum a far
reaching train and a near reaching
market can brush together in a strangely
intimate dance
good luck swinging about that one of the
city planners
the Dharavi slum performs no end of
services for itself and for the city at
large among other things it has 4,000
recycling units and 30,000 ragpickers
sorting 6,000 tons of rubbish every day
now that's recycled basically the
greenest of all humans are slum dwellers
in the developing world they use minimal
energy material and food and they
recycle everything here's one but they
are that green because they are so poor
and they do not choose to remain poor
nor should anyone in the developed world
require them to stay poor in order to
stay green they will climb the food
ladder toward more protein and they will
climb the energy ladder toward more
electricity this is in darby gentleman
named locksmith come by says for toilet
purposes we have to go outside and it's
a problem we have to go in the road the
electricity is on for two days then
offer two days or not on at all we don't
have much space for the children to play
in they use the road to play in
accidents take place again and again
I've not studied at all and illiterate
for work I stitch government jeans and
pants it's fine if the workday ends late
I want to educate my kids until the day
I die
I'll educate them as long as I'm around
that's guaranteed I don't want to be in
the way of this gentleman he will make
these things happen
parents in the slums pool their money in
higher teachers often their neighbours
to do private private tiny unofficial
schools and that education going on in
those places changes the world they're
often a very good school sometimes
better than the official ones so the big
event in the world is that for the next
30 years you're going to have a world
full of young people in new cities and
the global South and the rest of us in
old cities being old people and the
global north now where do you think the
action is going to be now if you want to
save a village here's what it takes
bear the city in mind you want to
good road to town you want a good
cellphone connection this of course is
one on trip chases slides from Nokia it
is no accident that the developing world
now dominates cell phone innovations
they did that with $10 cell phones
imagine what they're going to do with
$20 smart phones right now they're
charging those cell phone batteries with
diesel fuel hauled in by truck but if
they can get electricity grid
electricity then the village comes back
to life and it is no longer a dark trap
because village is emptying out is the
main thing is making cities green in the
developing world the people leave the
poverty trap an ecological disaster of
subsistence farming behind when they're
gone the natural environment recovers
and those who remain in the village
developed cash crops on better land for
the new customers in town in the
developed world where we are cities are
green because the city dwellers use less
energy and materials than people in the
suburbs or countryside so come to my
book and one of its points is that
cities are green both in the developed
world in the developing world as soon as
people move into town they immediately
start having fewer children in the
developed world it's way below actually
the replacement birth rate of 2.1 and is
rapidly getting there in the developing
world there are four major news items in
my book the thing that people keep
asking about these is the Man Bites Dog
story nuclear power is Green genetic
engineering is green and geoengineering
may well be necessary because that's the
other main whole Earth event that's
going on besides this huge move to towns
this is well finally coming to the
developing world and that's climate
change I'm not going to do much on that
you've all seen the J curves and whatnot
but here's a little sample of how gnarly
it gets this is a quick look why the
climate news is going to keep being
worse than we expected sooner than we
expect climate is a profoundly complex
non-linear system full of wanna runaway
positive feedbacks hidden
specials and irrevocable tipping points
these are some of the ones that we know
about now one that's is an interesting
positive feedback is this one the Arctic
ice melted forty years ahead of schedule
because of a positive feedback situation
bright ice like this reflects sunlight
but dark water doesn't is it give me
some dark water there is the dark water
yeah see and the room went up and then I
went dark bright ice reflects sunlight
dark water absorbs it warm water makes
less ice which then makes more water
which makes less ice and that's positive
feedback and keeps going until there
isn't any ice left similar dynamics are
going on with tundra and methane with
the rain forests drying out and going
away and taking the rain the clouds and
a million species with them but
something I constantly want to do is
look at the next interesting thing going
on and the next interesting thing to me
is well it's relatively easy to detect
positive feedbacks because it's you know
things taking off negative feedbacks can
be mysterious there's one and they are
the good news so it there is this
unidentified sink of carbon which is
quite large
and you can see how big it is but they
don't know where it's going these
decades a lot of carbon is disappearing
from the air we don't know where it's
going and that's you know the good news
is it's happening the bad news is we
don't know what's happening or why it's
happening so we don't know how to help
it or at least stop hindering it another
such story is peculiarities of this
wonderful l.joe cockle if the four named
Amelia Amelia honey off Huxley I named
for Thomas Huxley he hawks to his
friends it forms huge balloons that are
visible from space yet brightens the
Earth's albedo and it does that draws
down vast quantities of carbon into its
hard shell and then politely sinks the
bottom of the ocean in the process it
emits dimethyl sulfide particles that
become the nuclei for water droplets
thereby creating reflective clouds and
it prospers even when the sea becomes
acidic which is what's happening these
days now a few weeks ago I spoke at the
State Department and one slide it's
unreadable but it gives you a sense of
where the climate refugees are expected
as the problems of climate continue to
multiply over the next year's and
decades climate events are expected to
lead not only the massive motions and
movements of refugees but well you get
with that as resource Wars chaos Wars
and potentially a massive die back if
climate keeps being catastrophic Jim
Lovelock's version of this is that if we
go to the warmer world of five degrees
Celsius warmer that he thinks we are now
in progress toward there carrying
capacity for maybe a billion and a half
humans we're already seeing bits and
pieces to this Darfur is a classic case
basically drought is great civilization
killer it is the great carrying capacity
reducer and it leads to people fighting
over the diminished resources left we're
also seeing not only fire but fire
squared as they say in Australia and the
American West and lots of other places
it's the trees dry out they born burn
more easily you get another positive
feedback there they're putting a lot of
carbon into the air when they burn one
of the dyers potential places is the
Himalayan plateau because global warming
is melting those glaciers such as these
in Bhutan and those glaciers feed 40
give water to 40% of humanity look at
the major rivers that are the Indus
these are meters the Indus Ganges
Brahmaputra become Irrawaddy Yangtze and
the Yellow River
talk about the developing world that's
where everybody leaves so greenhouse
gases how do we reduce greenhouse gases
let's get down to what it takes to make
baseload erect electricity a lot of it
in the developing developed world a lot
coming in the developing world I was
just with Peter Schwartz and Friends and
Cambodia Singapore and Vietnam a couple
weeks ago and you know what those people
get any money at all are getting air
conditioning it's going to be Miami
globally that's a lot of energy so the
real fact is our climate problems that
caused me only buy coal which is the
cheapest source of energy everyone who
keep burning it until governments make
it expensive
cities require baseload power
electricity available all the time wind
and solar so far can't provide it the
only carbon free substitutes for coal
are nuclear and hydro and hydro most of
the world has already maxed out now I
thought we might have solar beam down
from space and then I got beaten up by
Elon Musk who knows a lot about space
and a lot about solar and said no
[ __ ] way even if we could get the
equipment to orbit for free beaming it
down direct Anna's on the ground and the
rest of it is just too expensive and
impossible so forget it
so sorry about space solar which would
have been nice and beyond 24/7 but we're
back to hydro nuclear bear in mind that
the folks in the developing world want
that electricity they will either at
present get it from coal or from nuclear
and while we're at it the developed
world
alikes didn't leave the lights on at
night that's what we do that's we how we
refer to cities bright lights so coal
and nuclear this is the main green
argument that I see for nuclear compare
what happens to the waste products from
nuclear versus coal a bear in mind the
differences in pure scale here if all
the electricity you used in your
lifetime came from nuclear the waste
would just fill a coke can
whereas a normal one gigawatt gigawatt
coke plant burns it II real cars of coal
a day each car holding a hundred tons of
coal and that turns into nineteen
thousand tons of carbon dioxide plus no
end of slurry fly-ash atmospheric
mercury and the rest where does that
carbon dioxide go now the nuclear waste
is small and contained two casts a year
for a gigawatt plant whereas the coal
eight million tons of carbon dioxide go
into the atmosphere where we can't do
much about it we don't even know what
the hell it's doing there wait it's sure
is hard to get it back and when you
compare the lifetime emissions per
kilowatt hour from the various energy
sources nuclear when you add it all up
compares to hydro and wind and it's a
head of a solar so far now if you don't
think that coal and nuclear are
competitive
just ask the miners in Australia who
mined for coal
they don't want nuclear okay wind and
solar I remember the whole earth
catalogue was wind was was when wind was
something to put on your roof when now
is huge infrastructure that's great
but that's where the efficiency is is it
very high altitude as you can get and
with this big diameter blades you can't
eat getting out to over 300 so I'm going
up to 500 feet and by the way the wind
and people are usually in different
places so you have very long power lines
or their usual expense and loss of
efficiency moving the electricity you
get from wind into town and in fact
they're always supplemented with
gas-fired plants because of the the wind
Otto is blowing problem the solar issue
is one not only that the solar isn't a
massive supplier of energy yet in fact
they say there's 10 gigawatts of solar
capacity in the world well since that's
14 percent efficient in terms of that is
not efficient but in terms of you know
when the Sun is on and everything is
working that means you get one
present in the world we get 1.4
gigawatts of electricity from solar
which is less than one large nuclear
plant and the footprint issue go to a
pretty place in the desert and think
about what it will look like when you
drop the solar panels for these large
solar farms on them it is basically a
bulldozing process and you might think
that this is a particularly nice part of
the Southern California desert but as
you can see from the Google location and
the photographs in the middle of nowhere
and it is exactly the kind of place that
will be double those for these things so
all griffiths is in the audience you
will recognize part of what I'm doing
with his talk a few weeks back
civilization currently uses about 16
terawatts of power most of it from
combustion getting it to level off
getting our climate to level off by
getting the parts per million of carbon
dioxide down to 450 over the next 25
years
requires replacing 13 terawatts with new
clean energy and he says you can do it
with 30,000 square miles of solar panels
15,000 square miles of mirrors this was
in 25 years 25 2.6 million turbines
which take about a hundred thousand
square miles give or take good locations
1.5 million square miles of engineered
algae for the biofuels
geothermal finally going and takes over
27,000 steam turbines and this is you
can keep those footprints down to that
point by saying let's get the three
gigawatts from nuclear and that the only
3900 one gigawatt reactors
that's mitigation that's what it takes
and it all up and it's an area about the
size of North America that's all refers
to is renewest and
so you know talk about a sacrificial
sacrifice this is a world sacrifice here
we go all of North America is gonna give
up its sunlight and landscape everything
else everybody will have solar and wind
energy not going to happen something you
didn't make it into the book there's a
lot of stuff in the book about how
radiation is not as worrisome as we
imagined and it's
one of the reasons that Jim Lovelock is
so comfortable with nuclear is because
he used to be his professional really
originally was in medicine and he worked
with isotopes and it's completely
familiar with how relatively manageable
and under as' radiation is after all we
used in the hospital all the time but
then there's this thing called radiation
for Mises and here's a little story the
case of the radioactive Taiwan apartment
houses so there was this contaminated
recycled steel that had a whole bunch of
radioactive cobalt 60 I went into one
hundred and eighty buildings in Taiwan
ten thousand people lived there and they
were exposed to an average of 1,300
millirem a year for 20 years in
succession so there are cumulative dose
per person range from 40,000 to 600,000
all around bear in mind that people at
Chernobyl died when they're exposed to
$400,000 I'm in an acute situation this
is product versus acute they did the
studies in Taiwan what's the normal
cancer rate there among a similar
population of 10,000 people and normally
it would be out of 10,000 people in that
20 years 232 would die of cancer that's
the general population now for the
10,000 that were exposed to all this
radiation big question is how many of
them died of cancer in that 20 years
time and I have a welcome guesses twice
as many 603 times many 400 half 152 3 5
110 do I hear anything more 0 that would
be a miracle actually that one's the
closest
seven of those people died from cancer
in that 20-year period of time in other
words they had 3% of the normal cancer
rate thanks to being exposed all that
damn radiation here's the chart from the
paper and the paper which is titled is
chronic radiation and effective
prophylactic against cancer was
published in 2004 in the Journal of
American Journal of the Surgeons and
whatever it is to find print to read
something weird is going on with
radiation and studies are finally now
going forward you see you know is
radiation good for you you immediately
start thinking gosh maybe this could
take care of our spent-fuel problem
instead of burying it in the ground
we'll carve it up in portable hunks and
sell it to people to put under their bed
so they won't get cancer the hell of it
is is he actually worked we should have
some in the lobby okay the big bugbear
Chernobyl
what was it 46 workers died in 1940
their cause
happened because the government didn't
yet that's very easily treated in
children and everybody except those nine
that got the thyroid cancer is now cured
the nine they didn't treat fast enough
did die you go to Chernobyl now lots of
people do and you know take a very dour
expression to take these really scary
photographs of how weird and awful it is
there and the reason thing to do that is
it's back to background radiation it's
like any other part of Ukraine or here
for that matter a few hotspots one of
the great things about radiation is is
really easy to pick up with a dosimeter
got your counter or whatever in there it
isn't pull it around it and then it
fades quickly that's what really for
your activity does so what you've now
got in the Chernobyl area is and this is
a great quote from one of the biologists
who study
the area for 15 years that the animals
came back because people stopped doing
the thing which is hardest on animals
which is farm and log and live in places
as soon as we move out and this is a
whole chapter I think in the world
without us the animals came back that's
a wolf
and we have wolves generally in that
part of the world they've reintroduced
some of the European bison and so on and
pretty out meanwhile this fifty thousand
people moved out and it is now
reforested and it looks quite beautiful
so the best thing and this is something
the United Nations recommended after
visiting there is that the area that's
main problem now is not radiation it's
very economically depressed and the best
thing they could have is tourists so
Chernobyl National Park would be I think
an amazing thing to have and once they
get the big sarcophagus over the the
exploded plant it'll probably last as
long as don't hinge and be even more
interesting to think about I'm gonna
brush by the whole question of
proliferation it's well to remember that
nuclear energy has dismantled more
nuclear weapons than any other activity
this is a for some reason quiet program
that buys out for heads from the
Russians and turns them into nuclear
power and in fact these a number of
warheads that have been converted as of
June twenty percent of nuclear power in
the u.s. comes from 20 percent of our
electricity comes from nuclear half of
that is coming from the Russian warheads
thank you and when we're finished with
errors we're gonna start using ours
there's probably no other civility
there's no other weapons system that has
as much civilian value in it when you
decommission it alright how about the
spent fuel standard thing when here's
all the spent fuel such a difficult
problem that there's no place in the
world where we can put spent fuel well
we were gonna put it in Yucca Mountain
but that's out like this row budgeted
about a month ago so where it is it is
where it's been for quite a while now in
dry cast storage and the various reactor
sites around the u.s.
around the world you can go there and be
photographed standing next to the thing
no bad thing will happen and it's a
perfectly decent interim solution while
we figure out whether we want to recycle
the stuff or burn it and integral fast
reactors or ticket the way they held
down in the ground if we want to stick
it away the hell down on the ground
we've already got a site that works work
very well for us which is the whip The
Waste Isolation something plant pilot
plant thank you and that's a pretty good
deal so you go down a half a mile into a
salt formation and it's pretty
interesting down there this is what it
looks like it's real easy to mine and
that salt gradually heals itself so what
do you whatever you put in there heals
and around it and here's a slide from
Jim cocoa who runs the environmental
oversight for the for the whip and
basically he says that this is how it
works that salt formation there's a lot
of formation they're now estimating that
if humanity use nothing but nuclear
power and did a once through with its
fuel into waste probably by then it
would be using some thorium and stuck it
in the ground
you could civilization could do that for
10,000 years and there'd still be room
down and there's a lot of formation to
stick it in the ground and stop worrying
about it this a lot of formation is been
there for 250 million years it's not
going anywhere
salt doesn't get into it doesn't get out
of it it's a really good place to park
this stuff some of you may have seen rep
Anderson when he was here talking about
that he was the science officer it's
India that made that go forward another
thing that people worry about is oh my
gosh what about moving this stuff around
it's so dangerous it's well the guys at
Sandia had some fun looking at how
dangerous that was crashed first at 60
miles per hour and then it
eighty miles per hour into a 700 ton
concrete wall
they have been broadsided by a 120 ton
locomotive traveling at 80 miles per
hour another physical test involve
dropping containers in a 30-foot
freefall onto steel reinforced concrete
comparable to hitting a concrete slab
head-on at 120 miles an hour they've
been dropped onto a 6 inch diameter
spike and the containers have been
burned in a pool of aviation fuel for 90
minutes at temperatures of more than
2,000 degrees Fahrenheit the result in
each case there were no ruptures or
significant damage to the used fuel
containers themselves although dented
and charred the containers remained
totally intact to protect the used fuel
they would carry don't you love her to
Anna voices so you know these things
been traveling around for tens to
thousands of miles on US highways and
there's been no accidents because this
is part of why these reasons and others
are why a good many of my fellow
environmentalists already noisily or
quietly support nuclear power James
Lovelock you've heard from James John
Holdren is now Obama's science advisor
has said many positive things about
nuclear he's the reason that Jared
Diamond when he was on this stage said
that he was in favor of nuclear power
Tim Flannery the biologist in Australia
is supporting it Paul Hawken says he was
converted by my book from being anti to
Pro so he not to think about whether you
want to read the book or not
Jesse AuSable at the Rockefeller
University has come out with a very good
article basically looking at footprint
analysis and saying nuclear is green and
renewables are not green Patrick Moore
was one of the cofounders of Greenpeace
he left their board he was their only
scientist and their senior leadership
and he left when he thought the
organization turned anti science he is
now spokesman for the nuclear industry
and he was a PhD in ecology and he still
pushes a forestation and
thermal among other things Al Gore says
very very quietly well I am NOT opposed
to nuclear power to expect to see some
modest increases in the use of nuclear
reactors I doubt that they will play a
significant role in most countries he's
mainly concerned about flirtation and
Bill McKibben is really quiet but he
says he expects that nuclear will
increase pretty much in line with what
the IPCC is suggesting and there's a
generation shift that's happened where a
lot of younger environmentalists are
finding themselves comfortable with
nuclear because the cold war doesn't
dominate their world climate change
dominates the world and nuclear goes
from being the problem to a solution
with that switch just to draw a couple
of interesting examples one was hued
Montefiore who was on the board of
friends the earth in britain some years
ago he said climate change is too
important he was coming out for nuclear
power and he was thrown off the board
someone know easily Oh
another interesting one is Stephen
Tisdale who from I think 2001 to 2007 or
so was head of Friends of the Earth UK
he said my change of mind wasn't sudden
but gradual over the past four years and
he finishes up it was kind of like a
religious conversion being anti-nuclear
was a essential part of being an
environmentalist for a long time but now
that I'm talking to a number of
environmentalists about this it's
actually quite widespread this view that
nuclear power is not ideal but it's
better than climate change then we come
to James Hansen when he said a while
back we've got to get from 483 hundred
and eighty seven parts per million of
carbon dioxide down to 350 that became
the rallying cry for a huge movement and
indeed there is a large 350 event
happening on October 24th worth
participating in but also January this
year James Hansen wrote an open letter
to Barack Obama saying coal plants are
factories of death the danger is farther
down the letter that the minority of
vehement anti-nuclear quote
environmentalists could cause
development of advanced safe nuclear
power
be slowed such the utilities are forced
to continue coal burning in order to
keep the lights on that is a
prescription for disaster 350.org
doesn't quote that very much so what's
gonna need to happen is coal has to be
made expensive climate has to be taken
as an issue by the throat for major
governmental areas European Union the
United States Canada China in India
those for all all act we might come out
okay if they don't open only some do
we're in a world of trouble because if
climate change gets to the point of
disrupting economic or social conditions
the government's could flip into total
self-preservation against other states
and then you get the downward spiral of
wars driving worsening climate driving
more desperate wars that's a positive
feedback you really really don't want
nukes are actually pretty familiar I
grew up in Rockford Illinois this is
just down there were highway boys it's
one of the reasons that Barack Obama who
was the senator from Illinois is we're
all totally comfortable with nuclear is
he a lot to do with these things in the
developing world that's now actually the
cutting edge of a lot of new
construction going on and we can rejoice
that so many countries are building
nuclear energy plants and we are doing
what we can to help them and I think of
particular interest to these customers
and maybe to us is a new technology
nuclear technology that most people
haven't heard about now this built on
the environmentalist idea of distributed
micro power that's the way we would
reduce losses from long power lines
building resilience and dad app - and
usually environmentalists mean solar and
wind and cogeneration but the new micro
reactors might work even better the
first one off the line is Russians are
building these small floating reactors
on barges 35 megawatts that they're
going to use along remember the melting
ice the shipping is now going to
commence along the complete shortcut
north of all of Europe and Asia along
Northern Cyprus see route as well as the
Northwest Passage so they are building
these and they're pouring concrete for
the ports along that route and this will
be the energy source they're also
selling them or will sell them to
coastal developing countries that would
like a quick 35 or 70 megawatts to power
the coastal town the school scale is
pretty interesting a large reactor these
days is 1.6 billion watts and 25 million
watt reactor 25 megawatt it's a 64th of
that size it's about one reactor one
small town
most of these micro reactors are meant
to be buried and relatively left alone
you don't need to do a lot of gardening
on them this is a design from Toshiba
here's one that over they designed
across the way at Lawrence Livermore Lab
here's one that claims it's going
commercial right away based in New
Mexico with the design from Los Alamos
uranium hydride technology the thing on
these micro reactors is they're
relatively cheap they're quick to build
and their designs evolve rapidly
all of them are meltdown proof and
proliferation proof and various forms
video proof there's another company in
Oregon called new scale it's designing a
light water reactor meant to be built in
modular form you put in one of these and
when you like it or you grow your town
or whatever in he had s'more an old
player in the game Babcock and Wilcox
has they've been building Navy reactors
for 50 years they're now getting into
this and they have a hundred and twenty
five megawatt modular reactor they're
coming out with the weirdest one
probably is is a thorium reactor that
designed by Lowell wood Freeman Dyson
loves it
it's being developed by Nathan Myhrvold
and terraPower they're based in
Washington this thing you stick in the
ground it has all the fuel that needs
for a lifetime which might be 60 years
and they just leave it there and it's
thorium so it's as doesn't have a lot of
the problems that we associate with
uranium okay that's enough on nukes
well this is kind of new key
yeah food apocalypse this is romantic
environmentalism at its worst it's a
visceral fuse what is seen as unnatural
basically vampires it's only unnatural
if you don't know the biology all
microbes swap genes promiscuously
promiscuously all the time the selection
pressure on problematic genes in the
wild is fierce genetic engineering
greatly reduces the huge impact of
Agriculture on natural systems and
you'll notice that a renowned
biodiversity biologists like Peter Raven
and Ed Wilson take no part in the
campaigns against the genetically
engineered food crops so then you ask
well who likes them well am I for one
like them and in the world
they're extremely popular Africa
especially once people catch on so in
South Africa we don't eat genetically
engineered sweet corn in this country we
just eat feed corn which becomes
cornmeal and tortillas and buns and
muffins and things like that but in
South Africa one of the most popular of
all foods there is white maize it is
genetically engineered and they love it
because it works so well for the farmers
heading off both pests and and weeds
remember about 40% of the world's crops
mostly in the developing world is lost
every year to weeds and to pests so for
that reason that because they work so
well against those this is the most
rapidly successful agricultural
innovation in history they're good for
the environment because among other
things they enable no-till farming that
protects the soil they reduce pesticide
use especially in things like bt cotton
and they increase yield and that frees
up more land to remain wild now this map
from 2006 is out of date because it
shows no African countries doing stuff
that's because the European
environmentalists with friends to the
earth International and Greenpeace
International went to enormous lengths
to terrify the leadership of the African
nations that this was poisoned
people starved as a result of that
directly and great harm was done but now
the agriculture the African nations are
finally getting up to speed and after a
decade of delay maybe two decades of
delay caused by greens in Europe there
is no good reason for genetically
engineered food crops be controversial I
think my fellow environmentalists have
been irrational in the subject and
really have done harm now if you got a
question about that
ask the new field council and bioethics
who took serious detailed exhaustive
study of the issue genetically modified
engineered food crops especially in
regard to the developing world and
basically said it is a moral imperative
to make GM food crops readily and
commercially available to people in
developing countries who want them bear
in mind besides the obvious matters the
food supply and enhanced attrition these
GE crops are can be made drought
tolerant salt tolerant and flood
tolerant as Pamela Ronald over here is
done with rice and they are going to be
crucial for adapting to climate change
in the developing world that's just the
beginning
genetic engineering is sort of the
sleepy backwater biotech these days as
we saw when Drew endy came here and
speak spoke synthetic biology is taking
off at a steep angle children are having
their minds focused on the opportunities
of screwing around with genes and the
question that I've been asking for the
last few years where are the green
biotech hackers has been answered by the
Jamboree the I Jim International
genetically engineered machine Jamboree
they hold in Cambridge every year
they're up to 21 countries
twelve hundred participants eighty four
teams and it's it's growing like Burning
Man that doubles every year I wonder if
there's an overlap
one of the things that I as a
preservationist restorationist one who
she dealt with is that I think the
genetically engineered bio controls
could help a lot with his invasive
species so you've got your Guam brown
snake you got your kudzu your French
broom your spartina your fill lilies
your red imported fire ant your zebra
mussels northern snakehead the King toad
that is poisoning Australia and most
graphic of all of the lamprey eel and
the huge question is how do you fight
back once you have an infestation well
the thing we've learned with bio
controls is the smaller the organism
that you point at trying to control an
invasive the better you can target it
exactly and it doesn't do the wrong
thing and that you can it's already
happening and with a lot of these in
fact the the cane toad they're
developing Irana virus a viral
engineered virus that may well hit off
the came to UM problem
there's organisms we like earthworm the
term for what they do now is called
ecosystem engineering or a niche
construction and what the earth one does
is it takes a crappie from its
standpoint areas soil and basically
improves it for itself but it abs be of
improved for a zillion other organisms
at the same time including us so we like
to have earthworms in the soil because
the garden grows better and the rest of
it another ecosystem engineer is the
beaver one of the reasons the
Yellowstone Park went to hell is because
when they got rid of the Wolves the elk
increased enormous Lee got lazy he
started eating up all of the trees down
around the rivers the riverine foliage
and trees went away there's nothing for
the Beavers to cut down and make dams
out up so that beavers went away then
they brought the wolf's back
the old got scared and ran for their
lives the way they're supposed to do if
you're an elk and then the trees grow up
the Beavers came back to cut down the
trees and make dams and this huge
enrichment that goes on with beaver
ponds is back in the Yellowstone Park
thanks to the Wolves here's another
famous ecosystem engineer Aldo Leopold
he inspired a lot of us in part by doing
kind of wild and crazy restoration and
150 acres in in Wisconsin brought the
trees back actually brought too many
back they had to cut a lot of them down
he undid serious dam is a really wrapped
out farm that he took over got it for
tree brought it back made it wonderful
as a whole although the Leopold museum
and Study Center they're now
he was undoing the damage 150 acres we
have damage done to a larger area maybe
the whole planet and that's going to get
hairy so here's part of why
geoengineering
is you can already see it being taken
seriously sooner than expected it's
because we're starting to face these
harsh realizations geoengineering is
direct intervention and climate
mechanisms the severely nonlinear
mysterious system that I spoke of that's
what makes it hairy but that's just the
beginning of the hairiness because then
you get to fine who's going to control
it how did the international agreements
work it is so cheap to do some of these
things you can change the climate for
everybody if you're a very rich person
or a country like say China we just said
you know we're tired of having Western
trying to go dry on us we're gonna put a
bunch of something in the atmosphere
that'll dim the sunlight a bit and sorry
about you guys downwind but that's what
we're doing well you know we do here or
downwind to them we see that a coal now
has red sunsets we would say that's
action an act of war we don't have
governance forms that can deal with
geoengineering yeah
and they need to start emerging now in
case all your wandering things well the
stuff can't possibly work this is one
that's most popular with climatologist
because they know it works
the Mount Pinatubo volcano exploded in
1991 the scent was it - 20 million tons
of sulfur dioxide 20 miles up into the
stratosphere that then cooled down the
planet by half a degree Celsius the ice
came back in the Arctic the polar bears
came back and the polar bears of the
years 92 and 93 are known as the
Pinatubo Cubs we now realize that it is
technically possible for humans to do
the same thing year after year as Mount
Pinatubo at a cost of maybe 30 billion a
year not that much
and if Mount Pinatubo had kept doing its
thing year after year it would have
taken the global temperature down not
half a degree Celsius but 3 degrees
Celsius guys we're really dubious about
all the stuff looked into it and the
modeling makes it look pretty good so
that's one idea that's the one that's
probably going to be experimented with
most first that really green one is the
one that Jonathan and the engineer
Stephen Salter came up with - atomized
seawater so that the salt water and tiny
particles goes up drives immediately get
a little grain of salt that becomes
nuclei for cloud particles you can
brighten the clouds all over the ocean
brighten the albedo of the earth sounds
great and this is a desperately cool
sailboat
that salt are designed with is flattener
sails as they're called another one that
Jim Lovelock and Chris raptly from the
Science Museum in London came up with is
the idea of having formed and foot pipes
that can reduce the thermocline problem
of the stratification of ocean when it
gets too warm and it dies it's also a
way to cool water around coral reefs or
to prevent hurricanes from coming
through another idea is artificial trees
Klaus Lackner came up with the idea of
doing air capture of carbon dioxide and
the idea would be to put these things
where you can sell the co2 as an
industrial chemical for greenhouses food
processing dry ice water treatments foam
fabrication and so on another idea that
everybody likes because the Indians came
up with first is what they call Terra
Preta or biochar which is basically
paralyzed smoldered plant ways
agricultural waste and logging waste and
just let it go into the ground that
turns bad soil and the good soil stays
down there for 4,000 years and it can be
done at any scale big question is
whether it can actually scale along the
scale is is part of what's going on we
are already dealing at scale the Nobel
prize-winning climatologist Paul Crutzen
calls our era our geological year at the
end throught I seen the human dominated
era we are stuck with its obligations
and the Whole Earth Catalog the first
words we are as gods might as well get
good at it those are innocent times
first words in the new book are we are
as gods and have to get good at it the
looming catastrophe of climate change is
forcing a change in environmental
thinking the reality of the developing
world where most people live is forcing
the change and environmental thinking
the shift is from an ideology to
pragmatism from a romantic
identification with nature to a
scientific examination of nature where
the thoroughness unlike anything we've
seen before we have to understand
ecology is not yet a predictive science
it needs to be one climatology is not
yet a predictive science it needs to be
one we are required by circumstances
ecosystem engineers at planet scale we
need to figure out how to do it with
this light a touch as possible and as
much intervention as necessary
ecological balance is too important for
sentiment and requires science the hell
term that the health of natural
infrastructure is too compromised for
passivity there requires engineering
what we call natural and what we call
human are inseparable we live one life
Thank You Kelly with a long now
foundation and a friend of Stewart's
bring up your questions as usual
legibility counts given to Peter who
will be vetting them so Stewart you
haven't always been so optimistic what
what flip that did say a little more
what are you speaking about I remember
in the 70s you wrote something applica
lips juggernaut hello there was
something about yeah we used to have
your supply of food wrapped around my
office young always hope for a disaster
because it means the new world that
they'll control this is sort of the
survivalist slash libertarian fantasy
and it's great but one out grows it
[Laughter]
so here's a question from Joe H you can
raise your hand if you want yeah there
it says over the years your message has
evolved but what about the ways of
spreading the message has your thinking
changed on the best way to change
people's minds yeah the Whole Earth
Catalog basically showed people things
and the whole this discipline is a work
of persuasion it's the sort of thing
that I do Global Business Network is a
consultant and researcher which is to
you notice they stated opinions kind of
strongly tonight but as Paul Safire
suggests a good futurist
may speak clearly but also a hold on to
the opinions kind of loosely because you
want a more persuasive argument or new
facts or better facts to be able to
change your opinion and so in a sense
the book is showing you how that's
happened with me and it's trying to show
some of the techniques of that happening
for anybody what we need is a lot more
people with a lot more accurate opinions
dealing with realities in the world some
of which I spoke about tonight so to
make that connection with the Whole
Earth Catalog which was a catalog of
tools for individuals right we're going
to change their lives of the world and
you'd have prescribed this very large
scale whole earth discipline what about
for the individuals here what are the
tools for them who go about their
everyday lives who may not be involved
in deciding policy and infrastructure do
you have tools for your whole worth
discipline I think thinking is a tool
this is not a book of things you well
actually there's a few actors a few
things get in there I mean how to bring
the birds back plant natives because the
exotic tree bushes don't support the
bogus that the birds
to eat let the Coyotes come back because
then they chase the cats indoors and
cats in the u.s. killed 100 million
Birds a year and kill and eat the deer
because 20 deer a square mile they take
down the undergrowth so far that the
birds go away along with the chipmunks
and squirrels and everybody else so
that's sort of practical but by and
large the book is about thinking and
these are examples of thinking
toric Rochette ask the question that
john bias who was earlier speaker maybe
a year ago four years ago was been
talked about the beginning of the
Anthropocene and says that we can
actually kind of have a role in deciding
what kind of climate we want so what
kind of climate do we want
since the climate has changed over time
is there an ideal climate that we're
aiming towards or in other words is the
assumption that the climate that we have
had recently the best climate and that
we're going to wear at the golden age of
climate on earth and we want to maintain
that climate or is there a better
climate that we should be aiming for
I'll bet it's exactly like the idea that
you hear about business climate no
surprises and so you know whatever it is
we're used to
I mean civilization is not used to
thinking about climate change because we
haven't had any the ten thousand years
that we've been growing our
civilizations been referred to as the
Fagen is the long summer it's been very
nice relatively steady weather except
for one or two blips for a long time
that's all we know so right now the
ideal is that there's some indications
that you get more life if it's colder
the ocean really likes it colder says
Jim Lovelock but we probably wouldn't
like it gypsy a Chung says is there a
sufficient supply of nuclear materials
to replace
gasps yeah this is one story the winner
oh my gosh we're running out of uranium
there's plenty of uranium right now it's
coming from some very nice stable
politically friendly places like Canada
and Australia but since the price went
up a little bit you know and this
Renaissance started to take place
instantly you had a lot of exploration
going on all over the world and uranium
finds are being made all over the world
that's just uranium so they're saying
several centuries worth that's without
reprocessing you reprocess it you cycle
it more the way the French do French for
80% nuclear and have the cleanest air in
Europe and they shut down their last
coal-fired plant four years ago and they
are selling four billion dollars worth
of nuclear energy to all of their
neighbors including Green Germany Italy
which shut down this nuclear plants
after Chernobyl and England what I
didn't know is that there's two
gigawatts of power going through the
tunnel underneath the English Channel to
nuclear England a long extension cord
actually apparently they're using a very
very high voltage retention itec system
that drives it with more efficiency
which you can do if you're underneath
the English Channel so there's plenty of
uranium if for some reason we got
worried about that there's three times
as much thorium as there is uranium and
it has if you were problems in terms of
weapons proliferation and various issues
it's why Lowell would and and Nathan
riffles are working on this thorium
reactor and then you've got some
reactors the fast breeders the integral
fast reactor is that in a sense make
their own fuel and they can take the
waste fuel we have now and and not
treated as waste but get some of the
rest of the ninety five percent of the
energy that's still in there and then
beyond that maybe maybe some day
infusion so this is not a supply limited
technology so you you kind of very
vividly painted why solar doesn't work
as a solution why wind won't why coal is
really bad what if you're wrong about
nuclear nuclear is also not so good
are we completely screwed at that point
because what snow where's a bob Coppock
says here what's your plan B here's the
helmet and you know we can go as nuclear
as we want it's not enough that was the
point it's all Griffiths mmm-hmm talk is
all of the things that we can think
about to mitigate greenhouse gas
releases and very in mind that once the
co2 is up there and it's up there it
stays there for a century plus methane
goes up and it comes down that's a good
thing to work on because you get a
short-term effect and that's why I think
that doing something to affect the
amount of sunlight that's hitting the
earth dimming it or reflecting it or
whatever some form of that is going to
happen to buy us time you don't want to
do that perpetually because then you
become dependent on it and you don't
want to do it perpetually because it
drives the oceans toward greater acidity
and it's not so good for the ozone layer
either but oh I think we're gonna be
getting in situations where we want to
buy time while we figure out all this
other stuff
okay here's that question from saw who
you quoted in your talk Oh
as Saul says as designers or engineers
in this rail we will choose the
aesthetic so how do we negotiate and
design the aesthetic we want the
aesthetic of nuclear I suppose there was
there's more than one way to do it is
there a process for that's such a good
question I wonder what's in your mind
Saul you want to stand up and say what
you're thinking about with aesthetic so
when if we are engineering the whole
planet we are making choices just how
much nuclear and I'm not sure I'm as
strongly in the solar and wind won't we
will do a lot of solar and wind as well
and so that will be part of the choice
of the aesthetic that's great and we
will choose to some respects by default
or by choice the aesthetic of how we all
live our lives and how much urbanism
there is etcetera etcetera etcetera in
in completely managed world
strangely industrial designers will have
their druthers and be deciding for us
the aesthetic of the whole well how do
we you know in the same how do we
the negotiation of what it looks like
and maybe what would you have it look
like
well industrial designers for a long
time I said well it should be sort of
streamlined and lean have a kind of a
satin finish on the metal I was Bruce
Sterling I'm at for fellowship chic you
know that that scene with the the market
and the train
so we got the message of horath it's big
it's the whole earth our earth catalogue
whole worth discipline what's the we're
now talking about long-term thinking
alone now so so what's the the long-term
vector in your vision of this discipline
how is it long-term how does it play out
in 10,000 years busted this is a one
century story and at one point the book
I say seize the century because a whole
lot of this stuff these three stories
the urbanism stories the biotechnology
story the climate change story I think
are gonna dominant already are
dominating this century and we are now
framing how they will dominate this
century and maybe the aesthetic of how
we respond to them and how they play out
but I think they're they're basically
century sized problems and will overs
are of in various directions and be
something unrecognizably different
hundred years from now so I sort of take
the singularity out on that one and say
well biotechnology you know it's sort of
sort its digesting nanotechnology and
going off and making all sorts of things
happen at the 100 nanometer scale a
major difference is how rapidly these
things are moving in a developing world
I try to give it a few hints of that
tonight but nuclear is taking off in the
developing world biotechnology is taking
off in the developing world
the resourcefulness not just in the
slums but in these places who are
inventing their aesthetic their world
way more than we are we're sort of
hanging on to the world that we got
familiar with these guys are inventing
the world so the inventiveness there is
going to be something that also plays
out in the century and then maybe by the
time or eighty percent urban and their
birth rate is dropped down below
replacement and everybody's dealing with
what you've been worried about it's
basically a population crash in the
later half of the century and we'll have
a world mostly run and populated by old
people and we'll look like some
something between Saint Lauderdale and
Fort Lauderdale and Japan that might be
relatively stable and then you know that
would need some other dislocations you
make the next century as interesting as
this one's going to be so there's a lot
of questions on nuclear which I don't
want to get stuck on because your book
is actually about lot of other things
besides that but one one chapter out of
nine right we're in California where you
know the anti-nuclear thing was partly
invented so this is a question from rich
mal Berg mountain malum malmberg what or
who introduced you to nuclear as a
solution what was a lightbulb because
you were not definitely always
pro-nuclear I was mildly Pro
anti-nuclear kind of you know going
along with various friends like Amory
Lovins and others who said well you know
it doesn't work and all these problems
and long-term thing the long-term issue
is huge but then the long now foundation
which does not take a position on this
or anything else as a foundation I am
hasten to say our guiding rule is taking
no sides so as a private individual I
was part of the long now foundation
board we went and visited Yucca Mountain
not for political reasons but we just
wanted to see what a hole in the
mountain looked like because of the hole
that we want to build in the Eastern
Nevada mountain and we learned a lot
about holes and mountains actually from
going and the Yoakum
but while we were there we got sort of
scandalized by the tens of billions of
dollars that have been spent on this not
very interesting hole and it's not very
interesting place that looked like
Nayland semi reasonable place to put
nuclear what was the big issue and
realize that the arguments against and
then eventually for Yucca Mountain
became totally surreal and the problem
was 10,000 years well this was tough for
the long now board to go and realize the
problem was that these people were
thinking long term are we a recipe for
disaster are we going to unleash one
Yucca Mountain after another end of the
world and that was kind of a soul so a
good thing to do with a board meeting
boy so we searched our souls and Danny
Hillis said well you know they could
have built the same hole in the ground
for about a hundred million dollars and
I just said look we're gonna just put
the stuff here for a hundred years while
we think about it it probably would have
been okay so that the pathology came
with trying to control and plan for a
hundred and ten thousand now they're
saying under thought no it's got to be a
million years you can't plan for a
million years you can't plan for ten
thousand years we can do is set things
in motion so that the future people have
plenty of options as centuries roll by
and indeed Canada decided not to do
permanent burial of its nuclear waste
because that would remove the option for
future generations to use that waste for
recycling or for some other purpose you
know carve it up and put it under
people's beds because it cures cancer
you know really get to know in advance
what you're gonna want to do with this
step so to throw it down a deep hole in
the ground and forget about it he is
actually irresponsible that was part of
the realization that we came out of from
the ariake mountain trip I'll just add
one other thought I had was you may
remember a few years ago saffle got
interested in this Sandia had a series
of meetings by science fiction writers
and various other people to try to
figure out what the signage should be
over the whip so that nobody would dig
down and come across this nuclear waste
some time hence and and well English
would probably be if they got into a
whole row set up this kind of set of
issues and well we'll have big gnarly
spiky art or yeah and then they went and
then they were gonna have things buried
like what's that Nova Scotia there's
layers you know if you get down to layer
and it's really scaring it down to
another layer it's even scarier and you
think about what a god awful waste of
government money and thought the stuffs
down half a mile it's in the middle of a
3,000 foot thick salt formation in which
there is nothing but salt and there's
quite a lot of it 250 miles in most
directions of this 3,000 miles it's a
lot of formation why in god's name would
anybody go digging down there
they would only do it if you put up some
weird sign that said don't date here so
your book in some ways is the
conversation with greens or even
conversation with yourself as a greeny
yeah and in some ways one of the
interesting things about greenness is
that it has always been sort of a
liberal thing when a Martian from outer
space which would suspect that this
would be the most conservative
politically thing in the world and what
I'm wondering is is when used to have
green that's embracing nuclear power and
directly modify crops is this sort of a
Republican green
it's I mean it is in Europe it's
starting day in England in places like
that there's a lag here that it's
difficult to explain but look 100 years
ago conservation really was for
conservatives it was duck hunters in
Teddy Roosevelt that was who was really
really successfully pushing conservation
in this country and us progressives or
for progress remember and then we got
scared of it and you got worried that
the technology was going to do bad
things and then this capitalist engine
of progress bothered us because it
seemed to be unfair and so progressives
turned against progress and against
capitalism and then the Conservatives
who like capitalism said what's with
that and so then environmental so
becoming this kind of leftist thing and
then the people who are on the right say
well I'm on the right so therefore I'm
an environmentalist and then you have
these are outcomes like a whole lot of
conservatives who cannot take climate
change seriously because doing so would
mean thinking that Al Gore was right
about something and they can't bear the
thought so you've got this weirdness of
that environmental movement has become
politically way too specialized
certainly in in North America and in
Europe what about China
tell me about China but you know the
people who are building all these
windmills and solar Lansing the nuclear
reactors are they conservative or
liberal in terms actually sort of leads
into my other question which is you had
a throne you were going to tell me about
China
you know throwaway line about that the
rise of the West is over yeah so say
more about that what do you mean because
I think that has something to do with
with the answer about China is is it's a
neither/nor
it's it's it's a triangulation I think
that's why it's interesting is because
it's not doesn't fit into our normal
dialectic you know they see the
Republican or Democrat left or right you
have China what is it they're the other
the other the other so so what do you
said that the rise of the West is over
what did you mean there's great book
called the rise of the West by Willie
McNeil it is a great book it's the best
one volume history I think we've got and
it's basically a thousand years of
Europe figuring out a number of things
in North America getting in on the act
and Guns Germs and Steel that was our
game and by and by everybody else caught
on to that one and are now in the
process of surpassing the inventors the
peasant life is increasingly over as
people move into the cities they these
are world cities they're connected to
everybody and they're economically
connected they're financially connected
it's funny when we have a a financial
meltdown in the West who's doing just
fine will the informal economy is barely
paying any in fact it's a it's a safety
net the countries that have this outlaw
economy when people lose their jobs and
the formal economy they have a place to
fall that didn't happen in New Orleans
so the action is partly where big cities
are something I didn't get into is
there's a new theory that Jeffrey West
and others came up with that cities have
this peculiarity that is different from
organisms as organisms get bigger they
get more efficient but they slow down so
a mouse has a pretty fast heartbeat and
only so many in his life and the
elephant has a very slow heart people
the same number in his life cities have
the same advantages this is part of the
economies of aggregation as they get
bigger they get more efficient they
don't slow down they speed up and the
study these guys did you know everything
from patents to length of electrical
cable to turnover in jobs to across the
board I'll fast people walk I'll pass
people talk in New York and the bigger
the faster and one of the byproducts of
that is the rate of innovation
as faster the bank of the city and
therefore these huge cities create huge
problems that's one of the things they
do in the world but they stay ahead of
the problems because of all the
innovation that they concentrated and so
cities are this amazing
this really is Burning Man stuff they
scale better than any other thing that
humans do and I think they're also the
greenest thing that humans do so if
cities are happening at this faster rate
and in this larger scale in the
developing world that tells me that
that's where the action is arise the
West is over so you have a book that's
in some ways disagreeing with a lot of
your friends every Levin's of the world
were very volatile and sometimes
political kind of disagreements yeah you
have this amazing knack to remain
friends with people you disagree with
frenemies of some sort of rather how do
you do that how do you how do you have
how do you disagree with people that are
your friends so well I'm interested in
that personally because I think it's an
incredible trait that you have of being
able to so fundamentally tell someone
they're wrong and without pissing them
off Philip tetlock on this stage gave a
great talk about the difference between
hedgehogs and foxes and one of the
peculiarities of foxes the others the
ones who have happy with many ideas
whereas Hedgehog has one big idea
advantage the Fox having many ideas is
you don't identify with whatever the
idea that you're entertaining this year
this month this week is whereas a
hedgehog kind of swears allegiance to
their idea come hell or high water come
what may that's who they are and there's
no room for actual discussion under
those circumstances foxes are law as
eager to have their mind changed
that's not the case with someone and the
hedgehog mode so one of the reasons I've
enjoyed talking with friends who don't
agree with me about stuff is I'm always
hoping they'll change my mind your own E
is young as the last time you changed
your mind who says that you're very
young so what what's almost been you
probably turned your book in about a
year ago so what was he on what was not
in your book that you wish was word that
you didn't get to well it's one of the
reasons I talk about this weird Taiwan
event of people exposed to serious
amounts of radiation having 3% the
cancer rate of the rest of the there
well I am paying more attention to
hormesis literature there's a guy
getting his name now who's been looking
at this for 20 years he claims one of
the questions is what's the optimal
amount of free DEA ssin and he says that
basically 6,000 or milligram a year is
good for you less than that you're not
getting as much radiation as you should
have more than that it's gonna start
hurting you or therethere spas in
Eastern Europe
yeah I mean you know when Bernie
activity was first discovered Marie
Curie and all that stuff she got sick
for him because she did indeed overdose
but various people were going to spas
that are we're hot then and they're on
now maybe it's just getting naked in hot
water that makes them better but the hot
water is hot in various ways so question
from Adam long now says cities plus GMOs
plus nuclear are we creating a Blade
Runner world and which nature will be
pushed out now the ideas is to give Gaia
a chance I think one of the sort of
realizations that come out of this body
of research about three years of it is
that concentrating harmful things is a
good idea
so concentrating people in cities is a
good idea once where a T percent of us
are in city
cities are only three percent of the
land area so we're taking a whole lot of
pressure off the natural landscape to
keep doing as Guyon duties I would like
to see lumber basically come from
plantations some of them genetically
engineered so we stopped cutting wild
trees please my wife and I were in
Tasmania and we saw the eucalyptus reg
nuns that are these 300 foot high
hardwood trees that break your heart
they're so beautiful and while some are
being protected they're basically being
cut down and chipped for cardboard and
you know that makes me crazy
plantations you should get straight
grain close green beautiful lumber
ohio's quality you want just do it
same thing with mariculture with
agriculture with more intense farming
and organic farming some of it on
smaller areas all of that frees up more
of the countryside now here's a weird
thing going on at least in the u.s. I
don't know what's happening in the world
there's fewer hundreds and fishermen
going out in the bush and now some of
our environmental organizations are in
trouble because they get their best
funding from people who hike a lot and
we're running out of people who hike a
lot now personally that's fine with me
I'm out in a trail then I see another
person the day is ruined but
it's not apparently good for the
landscape to not have some people
engaging it in various forms and one of
the thing the book goes into a whole lot
that didn't talk about it all tonight is
ways of engaging landscape and one of
the things I push very strongly is is
the people who've been at at the longest
in this country Indians in Japan I knew
mayuri's in New Zealand and the cross
there are people all over the world
who've lived there a long time and know
how to live there who are not being
listened to as much as they should and
that's part of my I guess long-term plan
is to be sure they stay intact be sure
their traditions stay intact before
their language stays intact and that
they can be part of the growing wisdom
of how to live well on the earth do you
think that we need a governance level of
a whole earth governance level that we
don't have right now are you kind of
part of the secret one world order to
you know global government I mean where
does all that fit into it that's the
aesthetic black helicopters black
helicopters we'll have an answer to that
when and if we get on the other side of
these two engineering questions now the
way I would hope the geoengineering
emerges is by lots and lots and lots of
meetings that include all of the people
who are serious in the business of the
very and there's a dozen ideas out there
now they should be not only meeting and
moving their ideas forward but about
meeting with each other meeting with
getting some government money for a
change it's all been private money maybe
more private money is called for for a
while we need serious research we need
to get things beyond the scientists who
are doing it as a hobby and in at the
hands of engineers who can start
actually trying things see if they work
intervene hither and yon a little bit
the climate see what happens
build the norms through that over enough
time and you don't need the Chinese
Prime Minister to tell you what to do
but on the other hand and this is a
point that that
Peter Schwartz is making these days we
imagine that democracy is going to
emerge outside the West and actually
what they do outside the West is a lot
more like what China does basically
where Singapore does a form of autocracy
there's pretty damn benign and one
result of that is that in China for
example you have a nation run by
engineers you think oh and there's some
problems with that well how would you
like to have a nation run by lawyers so
I think I've read every all of your
books I read every one of the Whole
Earth Catalog every page of all the
catalogs there with cybernetic frontiers
I read your book on the Media Lab I read
your book on the clock and of course the
book on planning how buildings learned I
think this is your best book it's really
great it does not have in it your
research which is on the web correct
yeah what a setup
yes bnotes dot-com is the online version
of this book and it is the place where I
get to put all the charts and graphs and
photographs and live links and the great
thing about the web now is all this a
little bit difficult with books though
thank goodness for google books because
I can often if I'm quoting something
from a book and it's is previewed in
Google Books I can take you to the page
with a link where that quote is you can
see the context and go from page to page
and then decide whether you want to buy
the book with magazine articles is
fantastic you get to see the whole damn
article you can get to see if I am you
know taking something out of context
what is that article linked to basically
you can enter the world of my research
best of all is my successful research so
the links that are in there are the
things that actually led somewhere
rather than the blind alleys they went
down is great fun to do it so as a form
of publishing instead of this seven
month wait
you know between finishing the book and
you guys having in your hands I'd make a
correction in the online version and it
is there right now so it allows me to
update things I have say some things
about Yucca Mountain and the book that
are now out of date thanks to it being
zero budgeted just fine but then that
let me is one I can put that in there
and then I can add a whole bunch more
stuff as I did here tonight about the
whip we the kind of diagram say here
plus more information plus lots of links
so the question in my mind it's
laborious to do this there's probably
you know thousand links and all that
stuff gonna be in this online version of
the book and it's not the whole text
Viking was not happy with the idea of
the whole text being there for free so
everything that is annotated is there so
it's probably a third or half of the
text kind of chopped up but the whole
connected body of research that comes
out of is there and I hope that all
nonfiction books will have online lives
like this because that's what I would
like to read in your book for example
right directly where were a lot of
questions tonight about where what were
your source is what were the references
and I would direct people to to those FB
notes SP notes dot-com and you can go
see the Taiwanese story on your own and
we had fourteen authors various
scientists and medical professionals in
Taiwan they're pretty serious about it I
don't know if they're serious enough to
be irradiating their citizenry at them
it's a great book I highly recommend it
and Stewart will actually be signing
books back there right now for those who
wanted I got a green pen thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
you